good morning it is amazing to see all of
you i'm so excited i really thought
people say they'll come to a 730 event
but how many really want to get up and
come to where they said they'd go
especially some who have to start i have
a friend here from way out in virginia
Debbie came started at five o'clock to
get here thank you a number of you have
come from far places this was
uncomfortable would anyone who was there
last night at our dinner with rush
limbaugh please stand up stand up oh my
god whoa give yourself a hand really
that is fabulous this shows your
commitment so good morning my name is
Ginny thomas i'm the associate vice
president for Washington operations for
hillsdale college I used to work here in
this building with a number of my
friends who are here Matt and Bridget
and others from heritage for about 10
years so this is a new transition for me
with me today are my colleagues in the
DC office of Hillsdale College David Bob
who is our director of the center of
constitutional studies and citizenship
David stand up where's David David we
have Jennifer Powell Jennifer pow is our
office manager please stand up she came
all the way from Dallas to join us to
make them make our office run smoothly
we love that we have Jeff Brewer please
stand up a Hillsdale grad
Jeff is a research associate and gisela
is a consultant with us Joe please stand
up Joe does a lot of our media work and
he's doing a great job we're getting
more press and more people all the time
so we've got a good momentum started on
behalf of Hillsdale College is Allen
Peake Kirby jr. center for
constitutional studies and citizenship
we welcome you to the first monthly
gathering of like-minded patriots who
realize the urgent need to gather to
teach to renew first principles and
constitutional limited government this
is an effort to build a community to
find a friend bring more people together
every month the first Friday we've moved
a few you'll notice on the flyer for
holidays we're moving until we get our
building up and operational across the
street 227 massachusetts avenue
northeast for those who want to take a
tour i think david you should find David
afterwards because he's going to take
some people over to see the building if
you want to see it but it won't be open
until sep tember 2010 so until then
we're going to be moving around the city
in different locations this time
heritage has allowed us to come here
next time it's the Metropolitan Club
because of a friend to my right and then
on in February we're going to the
Supreme Court because of a friend in my
life and and we'll be moving around this
city you'll have to keep up with us but
I think it'll be fun and we'll find some
new friends each time we move around to
different places we urge you to build
this into your monthly schedule bring a
friend as I said meet new friends before
you leave just like there's groups in
town who are meeting and working
together and finding fellowship over
issues whether it's the prosperity
caucus or some of the other groups in
town this is an idea of finding people
who believe as Matt Spalding does that
it's time to focus on first principles
and limited government and find our
community and get better and better
together Washington the Washington
office of Hillsdale College will it will
eventually be across the street but we
have already
launched at least for Washington
activities that let me mention before I
introduce trip how to my right last
night we filled the rafters of the
Mayflower Hotel with the annual
Churchill dinner featuring Rush Limbaugh
and it was a great time we all of you
who were there no it was a great time if
you weren't there i encourage you to
listen to russia's show today at twelve
o'clock i have a said i have a hunch
that you might play a few things from
that from that presentation last night
so Hillsdale is about to get a few more
visitors to the website i suspect we
also have the Washington Hillsdale
internship program and the George
Washington fellows program if you're a
Hillsdale intern or a fellow would you
please stand up I think we have them
visiting today a former intern two stood
up okay and we also have the new Madison
fellows training program that's
developing for next week we want with
the Federalist Society who some of our
friends are here from there as well as
Heritage Foundation Matt and Mike Frank
are helping us and the three
organizations Hillsdale heritage in the
Federalist Society have joined hands and
together we're going to start with
teaching very senior Senate and House
staff on why principles matter in
politics how to read the Constitution
what went wrong with the administrative
state and why we've got a government out
of control Larry will come back next
week from Michigan thank you very much
and be the first speaker at lunch next
week next Tuesday and ed Meese will be
the speaker on Wednesday afternoon to
finish that session off and we'll have
probably four sessions for these Madison
fellows they're getting resources it's a
great program and it's a great
partnership with the federalist society
and heritage that Hillsdale is doing we
also serve Hillsdale alums who are in
the area if you're a Hillsdale alum you
kind of have to
stand up to if you're an alum could you
please stand up I'm sorry it keeps
people awake in the morning good and
they're helping us bring friends to
these monthly events so we have a small
army we're working and now you're awake
isn't it good we look forward to
opportunities to recruit excellent high
school students who are coming through
Washington who may be interested in the
finest liberal arts college in our
nation that's only two hours outside of
Detroit Michigan that they might not
otherwise get to but they'll get to
Washington so we're going to have an
opportunity to talk to them so without
further ado let me introduce trip Howell
whose idea this was to have monthly
first friday lectures where we start
talking to the community around
Washington about great ideas trip Howell
it was a Hillsdale alum also he started
out as a political director for a
Republican senator from Iowa actually
and I have gotten to know him and have
enjoyed him he's helped hair he's helped
Hillsdale find the building that we're
going to be in across the street he
serves as the international director of
Jones Lang LaSalle's mid-atlantic
brokerage group during his 23-year
commercial real estate career mr. Howell
has successfully representing
represented building owners and tenants
and he's quite successful in his own
right moving from politics to the real
business community trip
thank you very much it's neat being a
Hillsdale grad standing up here in
inaugurating this program but but let me
give a quick history I I came to
Washington 30 years ago actually in
January of 1979 as a heritage foundation
in turn under the whip program the
Washington Hillsdale internship program
and at that time the heritage foundation
was occupying a small former veterinary
clinic over on Stanton square and they
had 12 employees can you imagine
Hillsdale College 30 years from now in
Washington Larry yeah I think we'll have
about 2,000 employees it's a it's R it's
really neat seeing this this come
together and I'm pleased after events
like last night and you know having had
you know deep-set roots at Hillsdale
growing up in Detroit leaving in in 1980
the last time we bailed out an
automobile industry and coming to
Washington it was really great with the
foundation Hillsdale gave me but seeing
last night's event six hundred and fifty
fifty people at the Mayflower Hotel
listening to rush and listening to dr.
Arnn really position us in in what we
have ahead of us was was really
fantastic I'm pleased to introduce dr.
Arnn before becoming president of
Hillsdale eight years ago he served as
president of the claremont institute
from 1985 till 2000 he was also founding
chairman of the California Civil Rights
initiative which prohibited racial
preferences and state hiring contracting
and college admissions dr. Arnn received
his BA from Arkansas State University
and as MA and PhD in government from the
claremont graduate school he worked in
english in england as a research
assistant / sir martin gilbert the
official biographer of Sir Winston
Churchill it was there that dr. aren met
his wife Penny they have four children
katie henry allison tony most of my
think living in Hillsdale right now one
on it not one in California Hillsdale
dr. Arnn is doing a fantastic job
heading up our colleges fundraising
drive the founders campaign which to
date has raised over 440 million dollars
for endowed scholarships faculty chairs
and building and renovation projects and
and if you haven't been to the campus
I've had occasion to be back there the
last two Falls it is is just truly a
special place and the just the the
presence that it has from the the new
buildings on campus are fantastic and
now building here in Washington under
his leadership long rent running college
programs continue enjoy to enjoy much
success including the national
leadership seminars the Center for
constructive alternatives the von Mises
lecture series and free-market economics
and the monthly speech digest and Primus
which reaches which now reaches 1.7
million readers each month and with dr.
run at the helm Hillsdale College
remains true to his historic mission and
operates entirely free of any federal or
state taxpayer support ladies and
gentlemen I give you dr. Larry yarn
discussing the crisis of American
constitutionalism just one comment I
want to make we're recording this
morning's event and we're going to have
as will be the the form of this program
questions and answers in the later
portion of it if you could grab the
microphone that will be handed to you or
directed to you for your questions we
want to make sure we get those on tape
with that doctor
thank you trip and thank you Jennie we
did have a good night last night thank
you all for being there and I'm really
glad to see the students here this
morning because as you know college
students are basically vampires by habit
something dragged him up this morning I
don't know what it was I have just two
points the first is how do we know we're
in a constitutional crisis and the
second is what should we do about it I
was reading lately Reagan's time for
choosing speech from 1964 actually knew
the man who organized for him to give
that speech Henry salvatori who's a
friend of the heritage foundation in
hillsdale college and the Claremont
Institute was a friend of mine for 30
years he said in that speech in a
mocking way three times that they are
they keep saying they're going to bring
the full power of the national
government to bear upon this problem and
that agriculture was the one he talked
about the most and he made the point
that there isn't any constitutional
power to do those things and that was a
wonderful it was a radical and crazy
thing to do and it had amazing effects
for Reagan's life and for the politics
of the country and the amazing thing is
that the minute Ronald Reagan retired
the momentum went entirely out of that
side of his politics soon enough the end
of the Cold War came and the big debate
was the peace dividend and politicians
started doing what Reagan did not know
they took polls and they asked people
what they were worried about and our
constitutional system works in a certain
way it is a purely representative form
of government they take pride in that
fact in the Federalist the first purely
representative form of government ever
built and that means on a normal day
ordinary people don't have very much to
do in regard to the government and that
by the way is the reason why I opinion
polls change a lot as elections near if
you ask somebody what the big issue is
on their lives in April they will likely
tell you that they've got to remember to
pick up their dry cleaning and if you
ask them in October 15 the answers are a
lot better and that's because they have
the habit in them of participating as
the Constitution calls upon them to do
but if you live in a world where
anything is possible you can get Al Gore
running for the presidency on lost
luggage at airports and traffic jams in
suburbs which was by the way key
cornerstones of his first out of the box
set of things he was running for
president against george bush in 2004
and the reason is he asked and they told
him those are fleeting things but more
persistent things since the peace
dividend days came and the cold war was
over have been the first really great
one was education the first George Bush
ran that he wanted to be the education
president which led my my teacher
several of our teachers and several of
us here to our students of the man Harry
Jaffa to comment that education is not
an adjective and that his son the first
time I ever heard him give a speech was
in California and he said like 15 times
that he was busy teaching every child in
Texas to read and he knew that dan
Lungren whom he was their support for
governor California's going to teach
every child in California debris and
friend of mine after it was over said
what you think and I said we don't have
you ever taught a child to read because
I haven't and I never shall I mean
unless I do something like that when I
retire because it Hills del they they
can read
and our own children to learn to read in
kindergarten we read to them the point
is George Bush is not a school teacher
and he talks as if he is now it is a
proper function of state government to
be in charge of the teaching of children
to read but you would talk about that is
if you were a politician I think a
governor elected to a constitutional
office and his idea about education has
been the same since the first days it
was the idea in Texas Margaret Spellings
the current Secretary of Education has
been his education advisor from the
first days she came with him from Texas
and his idea is top-down testing and the
No Child Left Behind Act is the example
of that and there has been an attempt in
the last year's with some success to
apply that to colleges and the idea by
the way in principle is not necessarily
a bad idea and there are models of it
everywhere first where Margaret Thatcher
was education minister and a her first
education job in England and what she
did was top down testing there in Oxford
University the way they examined is they
have it's a really great system in
almost nerve-wracking therefore possible
degrees and one of them to failing
degree so it's not a degree I guess but
you get your whole grades and you get
your degree cited by a series of
examinations you take at the end of
three years at Oxford and those are
graded anonymously and not by your
professors who have taught you along the
way and so and by the way at Hillsdale
College we are working on curriculum
reforms right now that may well have
some element of that institution in them
and it's a it's a good idea right but
the question is is it a good idea for
the federal government to do that and
that's where you reach the question of a
constitutional crisis and two things
come up the first of all is if the
federal government imposed national as
is it as doing national testing across
the country what would it be like
it will be the test will be written by
the established academics and those are
the people who have given us this thing
that I mentioned last night that mance
Bali wrote that final say about that
will give us the Capitol Visitor Center
and that account of the Constitution and
what is the specific point of that thing
what is it the heart of that thing I
mean it is a painful embarrassment that
God was actually erased and he is still
visible but also the end education a lot
is made of that there but the ends of
Education are altered so not religion
morality and knowledge which are by the
way all three things that are outside us
and not subject to our will and
education which comes from the Latin
word for lead forth what it means is to
address oneself to that I can tell you
there's a bunch of hillsdale college
students here and they will tell you i
can tell you on their behalf and with
them it's painful and hard to do that
it's painful and hard to raise yourself
to a place where you look up and see
accurately hi things you have to give
yourself to it you have to forget
yourself to do it it is precisely not an
exercise of the will except in the
effort and determination to do it after
that the will must be surrendered you
must become one was the thing you are
attempting to observe but of course it
is the characteristic phenomenon of the
modern Academy that power is the
replacement of knowledge go and read the
founding document of the American
Association of University Professors
written by John Dewey 1915 it's called
the general report you can find it on
the internet and you will see if you
read it with care by the way it is
written the way John Dewey rights which
means it's almost unreadable
I myself would never have read it except
once John sober criticized me for being
against it in the clermont dirty books
and the minute i read the criticism I
thought God to help me I'm going to have
to read that document and I did read it
and and what it means is a new purpose
of the university is born which is to
manage the social evolution of the
society an exercise in power you see and
what is to guide it except academics
coming up with plans which is the
opposite phenomenon from the beholding
of the high ends that are the purpose
that are written in the nature of the
human being so the first problem is if
you make a uniformity in education today
you will make that one and it is an
exercise in despotism but the second
problem is you can't do that through the
federal government without violating the
spirit for sure but also the letter of
the Constitution and that means by the
way you cut it off from law and if
there's no law than what will rule well
those are the two alternatives I'm going
to say a little word about this in the
end because there's a work for us to do
a project for us all to undertake
something for us to work on but I will
just come in right now that the first
great piece of legislation regarding
education is the third of our for
organic laws in our history and it is
the kind of legislation that was
characteristic of American history for
its hard first 150 years and that is of
course the northwest ordinance and its
accompanying land ordinances there were
two I think especially the one of 1785
and what those do is they provide a
government asset round land as a request
for the support of Education in each
Township and the federal government's
involvement in
with that it is a magnificent gift it's
an awesome thing it has reverberated
through American history that that gift
was given and we can never give such a
big gift again we don't have the
resources to do it by the time it got to
California was 436 of the Western land I
guess that would be 18 problem and you
can see what I studied in it and that
you see what that was that's a general
law you can read it quickly it has
massive implications and there are
almost no details a pattern we should
all custom ourselves to the extent that
we work on policy in the effort of
writing such things we should try to
reduce complications when we brought to
California Civil Rights initiative Arnie
Steinberg that was here last night
headed up the effort to do it all a
bunch of lawyers god help us there were
a bunch of really good lawyers Charles
freed and people like that they helped
write it and it took six months and the
reason is our criteria was we had to be
able to put it on the back of our
business card all of it and it had to be
comprehensible to the ordinary I and
understanding and by the way if you make
laws like that you can't make very many
and they will be limited in their effect
although by the way grand in their
meaning and today if you accept title
for of the Higher Education Act which is
the thing we do not accept well we don't
accept any of the titles but that's them
the one that's hard not to accept
because it will increase your revenues
by about a third if you take money a
third is a lot right now with the
economy in a mess we'd like to have that
money
but what do you have to do the answer is
it's hard to say what you have to do
because the rules are contained in 375
pages that cannot be read I tell this
story too much but I'll tell it again I
was new at hillsdale college and i
called up our lawyer we have a lobbyist
here in town mr. pee-wee back there
talked to him once a while we pay him
money to probably 25 or 30 grand lately
but it'll probably be more soon to keep
the government away from us and I sent
him a note and I said you know send me
title for I'm going to read it and he
called me up and said no you have no use
doing that you won't build read it and I
said you know let's get those a lawyer
right I'm thinking I'm pretty smart
fella I told him that he said yeah I
can't read it either we keep a
specialist here to read it that's all
she knows the staff of the Department of
Education often calls her she has given
her life by the way and that is a
governing instrument by the way it just
been expanded a whole bunch last fall
and I don't know what's in it Ginny
wants us to join some outfit here in
Washington because she thinks they know
what's in it by the way how would you
know no one knows what's in it right you
can't know what's in it it's you ever
read a 300 Hagel
but there's a meaning in hegel I imagine
we're not drifting anymore we're moving
somewhere now and it has its hard side
and we should remember we should remark
what the hard side is it means that rich
people can lobby government to take the
property from other people for their
private inurnment that happens now that
is a offense against the nature of the
human being and it is common it means
that businesses can be taken over
increasingly out quite soon by unions
that will soon enough not have to have
secret ballots and will change the
nature of companies if they take them
over it means that speech rights are now
allocated if you read the works of Cass
Sunstein and modern academic University
of Chicago very intelligent man a nice
man to a good man what he says is it's
not equal if rich people can talk more
loudly than poor people and so the
government must allocate the right to
speak and it does the most regulated of
industries that's a big border so I'll
say as regulated as any I know is the
election industry and think what that
means you see because I said before this
is the first purely representative form
of government and that that means
something odd and you have to think for
just a second to know what it is
sovereignty means the legitimate title
to rule and in all governments before
ours whoever held sovereignty was part
of the government and so the king was
the executive branch in England for
example until Parliament and by the way
that's the reason why the two branches
are together in England it wasn't
designed that way the king picked key
people in
Parliament to be his ministers and they
helped him manage the Parliament but of
course as the Parliament got stronger
and the we and the King got weaker the
executive branch was just dragged into
the Parliament in Athens the people
would meet and vote as a legislature you
see all at once we don't have that here
what we have is a constitutional
majority that has but one way to control
the government and that is through
elections and if it is true that there
is now a party of the government very
large and connected in our country and
the government regulates elections
tightly down to who gives and what may
be said at what time with a plain and
obvious often commented upon purpose to
pick winners and losers as was
powerfully affected in the recent
election then of course there is a
danger that sovereignty will pass into
the government and that at a time when
the whole idea of Rights is corrupted to
mean things that it has never meant
before this word nature means two things
it means that it comes from the latin
word for birth and so of course it means
the process of beginning and growth by
which any living thing comes to be which
has implications for the family i work
in the college business and they have
met they have in nature when they're 19
they're young they can do anything but
they never did before so everything is
new for them it's a wonder to watch it
by the way because the combination of
capacity and promise and inexperience is
delightful that's that's on their side
right that's what they're like but you
should be a college president for a
little while some time and call
somebody's home and announce your name
this is Larry aren't calling
and mom or dad says oh my gosh why do
they do that right the kids 19 if they
were cheetahs or monkeys the parent
would not know who they are anymore not
for long sense you see because the act
of charity between parent and child it
taking so long to raise living beings is
fundamental to human society and we are
on a course willfully to discard that
right now and that brings up the second
thing that that word nature means which
means the thing itself whatever it is
that makes it what it is and if you lose
sight of the human being and you regard
it as an evolutionary thing something
changing the process of change
controllable by human hands then of
course in principle you may do anything
and the constitutional structures are
coming into place whereby you can do
that and so my last point is just the
work we should do we should form a party
of the Constitution and of the
Declaration of Independence it should be
our explicit text there is precedent for
this in 1787 in 1800 in 1860 think what
happened in 1860 because of course we at
Hillsdale participated in that for about
40 years nobody had known what to do
about the slavery issue they had
compromised it and put it off the
country gradually divided into a party
of the Declaration of Independence which
did not like slavery and did not like
the Constitution which had the
protections of slavery in it and the
party of the Constitution which like the
protections of slavery if I can take my
pig into Nebraska why can I not take my
slave said Stephen Douglas but the
constitutive the Declaration of
Independence becomes a self-evident line
and the interesting thing is that the
solution to that problem the political
solution the solution is ultimately
military but the political solution
found in this discovery which involved
close constitutional reading and an act
of submission and humility to the
Constitution if it's true that the
Constitution does not give us the power
to eliminate slavery in South Carolina
then hate it though we hate it we will
not do that thing instead we've bid it
to grow and that will mean it will be in
a minority in the Union and placed in
the course of ultimate extinction and so
those two documents were brought
together again and that was the powerful
thing that left nothing but war that's
the way to those who would preserve the
institution of slavery it was a piece of
constitutional reasoning alongside a
piece of reasoning about the natural
rights of the human being I think the
Declaration can be handy today because
something's different now than was 60
years ago when Franklin Roosevelt did
his wonders 70 years ago or however long
ago it was people don't trust the
government very much anymore they know
its partial they know it's a deal they
know it's ugly they know I should
probably try to get mine because I know
it's going to cost me if you spoke in
the name of equality if you said why cut
the taxes on ninety-five percent of the
people by your lights when I do it on 51
and then expropriate 49 and then turn to
the camera and say to people but do you
feel yourself powerful enough to make
sure you're in the favorite group what
we got rid of groups what if instead the
rule was everybody would get treated
precisely the same what if we had better
than the reagan tax cuts which were
magnificent what if we had the flat tax
and what if we justified it in the name
of equality and the proper operation of
the constitution and what if we led with
that not because we posit that it will
yield more revenue to the government
although that's a good enough thing and
not because we posit that it will help
the economy although that's a good
enough thing we will start with the fact
that it is an act of justice we should
complain about bureaucracy alive because
people don't trust it a good friend of
mine who helped think up most of these
arguments used to say when the
Republicans when the Congress changed
hands in 94 he used to say they should
hold hearings about the things that are
done did not the kilo thing from
Connecticut echo across the country but
by the way things are done like that
every day and they are done that by that
like that by people who can afford to
hire five hundred dollar lawyers an hour
is it more than that now probably is you
see and people who can't afford that in
Michigan by the way it's a travesty just
a year ago the state was flat broke so
of course they raise taxes no idea and
you know oh they actually did cut one
government program that let prisoners go
and I you know I the former treasurer of
the state I think his name is clay Tom
clay I think I heard a give presentation
and he said our incarceration rates are
higher than our neighbors and I said
what's our crime rate he said he didn't
know but who did they raise taxes on
they did a services tax and you can just
look even go down the list of who's
exempted from the services tax and it's
everybody around lobbyist in Lansing
Michigan the dry cleaners were not
existed the accounts and the lawyers
were exempted why you say people see
things like that it is unjust and a
point can be made about it and one
should do that and not dedicate the
building of the Department of Education
after the maker of the Great Society
we should read the Homestead Act and
think about that beautiful thing we
should remark that very large parts of
the western lands of the United States
are still in public hands and most of
them are in the Bureau of Land
Management and most of them are leased
out to private parties too far more to
ranch or something why should we not
give those to people on terms that if
they will live on them and use them for
five years they can have them that is
one of the most generous pieces of
legislation ever signed by any human
hand and it was signed at a time when in
Russia for example you had to have be a
friend of the Czar to own anything and
your ownership was only good so long as
the Czar like the look of you and here
to utter strangers to anybody we gave
them a place to live if they would just
do the American thing and live on it and
work it why should we not do that right
things like that why should we not think
of bold things that we can justify
specifically by the principles of the
American Revolution and its
constitutional practices and propose
them and fight for them come hell or
high water and say out loud that we will
lose on these things before we will
abandon them because our freedom is
wrapped up in them and we will lose that
if we abandon because that is where we
are and the last thing to do is we have
to become better students because most
of us including many of us in the
movement that holds the hope for the
future of the country don't know so much
about the country as we used to know
cannot accurately state how it was built
and why cannot give an account of the
nature of the human being which is of
course by the way the account that is
implicit and explicit in all the great
works of the Western Canada that gave
rise to the Declaration of Independence
constitution and we get lost because we
don't know those things because it's a
changing rapid world and by the time we
get in office it's too late and there is
no repair for that except to amend how
we live our lives and if we want to live
as free people we must live as free
people live including what we do with
our leisure the proper understanding of
which term we might well unruhe cover
and I think if we do all those things
beginning with a few of us and extending
to more and more and then ultimately
many then I think we will save our
freedom and I think if we don't do those
things that is lost and thank
yes sir it is oh man in his ideas and
then you go back to things that are
creeping socialist things even he didn't
discuss the advent of social security
and the amendment of the Constitution to
include income tax these things become a
foundation of our government and it
seems to me that there's no end to the
progression of socialism when you got a
guy like that who believes in the
founding principles and can't discuss
those things well yeah he was a
socialist pig and now it you know Rome
was not built in a day and by the way
these problems have taken more than a
century to overcome us the ideas behind
them really grew up they were actually
present in the pro-slavery movement in
the anthem antebellum America and where
they sort of you know if you read
William Graham Sumner and academic
people like that that's from the late
19th century and Woodrow Wilson and all
those people who went to study in
Germany that's from the early 19th
century so it took a long time for us to
get in this mess and my own view is by
the way is that you'd be pretty moderate
about what you would do what you would
try to do is sustained a scholarship of
freedom and a politics of freedom and
you would justify what you do step by
step and over time in the name of the
Constitution and that means you wouldn't
necessarily do anything about Social
Security except put it on a paying basis
and leave it I used to be very impatient
with Reagan myself I used to my friend
Bill rusher who used to work for me from
national overview you know I used to
complain about Reagan to him all the
time of course he knew Reagan very well
I know pretty well but he knew him well
and he'd say my boy you're going to
think back on this is a golden age wise
words but one of my complaints used to
be that they do social security and we
do IRAs IRS look very consequential now
and if there was a shift in the in what
you depend on for your retirement from
this public thing to this private thing
if George Bush had done the adjustments
that he had in mind in the ownership
society initiative which I very much
favored cannot imagine how he can have
abandoned it so quickly but you see you
you wouldn't have to do the Constitution
by the way that it's a liberal friends
are correct about something there's
latitude in it and it was meant to make
a powerful government you know Madison
and Hamilton had an agreement about that
you have to have a more powerful
government that will hurt before to
protect our rights and so that means
that if you were speaking in the name of
the Constitution and meaning it then
what you did in any given here might be
less than the whole always justified by
steps back in the direction of the whole
and if I felt Reagan myself it's not
that he didn't do enough he did a lot
given that he was at war and had to
broke her with enemies to get money for
the defense budget uh my real criticism
was he could have been even more his
first inaugural address which everybody
should go and read it's really great and
easy to find on the internet he said
that should have been his way all the
time and it mostly was and I think you
know that that is by the way partly the
function of an institution of learning
which of course can't really start with
anything narrowly political it has to
begin with an account of what you are
what's the difference between you and an
angel Madison said that the Constitution
was written in light of that distinction
what is that distinction not easy to
stay first time you're asked i can tell
you because I get to ask people for the
first time all the time it's it's a
delicious enterprise but you so you
start with an academic institution or a
few and then you start with a political
party some political party I don't know
if it's one that's exists today or some
other one but they become the
repositories of a certain kind of
understanding and they're working their
way back and by the way you know I know
a lot about the Constitution I learned
something about it every day and I'm
wrong sometimes and you know sometimes
my friends are wrong we correct each
other so as I say it it you don't have
to think about this progressively
dismiss that idea now think the way
older thought worked everything is
defined by its end and whatever its end
is it will become increasingly like that
over time and changing the end of
American politics begins with an
understanding and an argument like the
way to deal with that capital thing that
abomination underground is to make an
issue of it get control of the Congress
and have a public reopening with it
changed and scorned the idiots who put
those falsehoods in there and
misunderstandings right there's an
opportunity in that so that's what I
think I think it's not a progress things
are not like that they go in the
direction where people's hearts and
beliefs and purposes are and you can't
change all of those in a mass you can
change them one by one 10 by 10 and so
that's the big work right and i will
tell you by the way the situation is not
that bad because first of all look at
this election it was closed and the
situation was miserable and and
there wasn't really by anybody really
good-running so I you know I don't think
we're lost I think but I do think that I
don't and see if you look at it looks
like a ratchet right I ratchet is a
mechanistic device we're talking about
human belief you Minh beings in human
societies and if by the way you yourself
we ourselves is the way I should put it
fall prey to this thought that
determinism that we are determined by
material causes about us our freedom is
gone in our own hearts yes sir
dr. Arnn it's it's very difficult to
talk about human nature in Washington DC
especially if you live here do you have
any advice or maybe is there an indirect
approach move no I you see I don't know
about that david i think i think it
probably isn't because I what I really
think you know first of all I had the
honor and ever to have lived in the city
yeah I you know I I did run for office
one time if I'd been elected I would
have you know but that was a stupid
enterprise I guess what i think is my
impression of the city formed of 30
years yeah then those two guys who can't
bother couple Micah my precinct workers
down there what I'm now senior man in
heritage what I'm a senior man on my
faculty we were all that's all funny I
brought that up um my impression of the
city is not like what you say but i
think is people who gravitate here are
especially in the political side not the
lobbying side necessarily although a lot
of that too are mostly high minded
people and they want to serve especially
the young who come here so my own
impression from coming here a lot is
that that's not so true of course i have
a distorted view because i work where I
work and we have a really weird set of
institution so you can't really come
until you agree that you want to do what
we want to do and that bible a bible Eve
is essential to the proper functioning
of a college which means partnership
that word but you know my own
impressions of this city are people want
to know and by the way we're staking
something on that I mean we are pretty
building across the street and all that
stuff that's cool
and we can train our interns in there
and if we don't do anything else than
that we will have done something good
but if I'm right because what I'm
thinking and you know maybe it's crazy
is that people will get up early in the
morning and come and read a good book
and it'll be good for them if they do
that and I think that they should the
best of them and many of them must come
and read the book for the sake of
knowing what's in the book and not
finding out how they should deal with
cap and trade next week that's important
but to really put the argument together
against Captain trade here's the deal
here's here's where that goes it seems
to me serious academic people whether
they're bribe to do it or not say out
loud that there's a terrible crisis
coming and serious academic people say
that there is not and that gives rise to
the argument that we should put a cap on
production in the United States of
America and shift ourselves distinctly
toward a command economy now there's two
ways to judge that and one way is
scientifically which places the decision
in the hands of experts who are by the
way funded by people in politics or
politically and that is to say when you
make a judgment about a thing like that
you remember the purposes of the human
being and the purposes of the regime and
you don't surrender yourself to such
arguments lightly
you see and that but but political
decisions always turn any time they're
serious upon a deliberation about human
ends Winston Churchill led the British
people to a much more disastrous
expenditure against Adolf Hitler how did
he justify it but you must consider the
rule of the Nazi regime and the life
that it implies you'll never settle that
argument til you learn what a human
being is and you'll never settle it
technically because by the way even the
experts themselves are corrupted is
there not experts about ends yes sir
we'll take one more probably and we'll
go professor aren't I'm wondering if we
could be better students by maybe taking
a harder look at the arguments of the
anti-federalists in retrospect some of
their objections may have been quite on
spot at one point they even complained
about having a six-year term for US
senators the Articles of Confederation
makes mention of term limits and yet
today we have people sitting in the same
chair for thirty and forty years at a
time I'm just making a retrospect maybe
we need the anti-federalists again today
well I'll say three things about that
the first is no proper understanding of
the Constitution can be reached without
reading them and look at our
Constitution reader and look at our
American history reader in Hillsdale and
you'll find them in there the second is
evil and wicked though the Constitution
is it is the best thing of its kind ever
written by a lot by a very great lot and
the third thing is if we cut ourselves
off in my this is a Prudential judgment
it is what I make if we cut ourselves
off from that thing which has won the
loyalty of the American people for 200
years and put ourselves in the posture
that it was a mistake to begin with then
we cast ourselves into a void and think
of the intellectual climate today what
will we do today if we start over and so
my radical preference is not to do that
Thanks Thank You Larry that was great
well first our first event our first
principles on first friday thank you all
for coming I want to draw your attention
to next month Jing on Friday January
ninth we're going to be at the
Metropolitan Club the corner of 17th and
H a another old-fashioned place in
Washington where you have to wear a tie
and a coat and a skirt or I guess not
blue jeans but we we welcome you all
there on Friday january nine to hear
burton folsom and stephen moore talk
about do we need another new deal so
we'll see you we'll see after the
holidays thanks for coming okay
you